à 14 ans je perds mon papa à 21 ans je
me fais licenciés de mon premier job à
23 ans par épuisement
je change de vie et de carrière à 25 ans
je finis en procès avec mon meilleur
employeur et pourtant je suis devant
vous heureuse un peu stressé j'avoue
mais souriante
aujourd'hui je vais vous parler de la
carrière des actes de résilience que
j'ai pu faire pendant ma carrière
alors qu'est ce que la résilience je
sais pas si c'est un terme avec lequel
vous êtes vous êtes proche en
psychologie c'est la capacité des
individus à résister aux épreuves de la
vie en technique c'est la capacité des
métaux de tous les matériaux à résister
aux chocs ça très bien c'est la théorie
parfait maintenant passons à la pratique
alors on va revenir au début de
l'histoire
gêné en 1990 à genève je me souviens
d'une enfance heureuse je me souviens
d'une scolarité tout à fait normal et à
14 ans c'est la première épreuve à
passer
je perd l'un de mes repères et je vais
faire sans même le savoir
mon premier acte de résilience à 18 ans
on me demande de choisir ce que je vais
vouloir faire pour les 50 prochaines
années de ma vie
quel va être mon parcours universitaire
qu'est ce que je vais avoir envie de
réaliser qui à 18 ans est possible de
faire ça c'est absolument improbable
donc c'est à ce moment là que je vais
commencer à dessiner le schéma de soi à
18 ans on peut choisir de faire
exactement la même chose que ses parents
ou de faire complètement l' inverse
on peut choisir d'étudier sa passion on
peut choisir de créer des nouvelles
solutions comme une start up pour
pouvoir aider la communauté pour pouvoir
aider tout le monde
mais comment on choisit et bien tout
simplement moi j'ai créé un petit schéma
avec trois critères nos coeurs à l'adn
la connaissance et les expériences l'adn
ça va regrouper mon patrimoine génétique
mon éducation ce que j'ai pu vivre mes
connaissances
ce que je vais apprendre à l'école à
l'université c'est mon bagage théorique
et pour les expériences c'est ce qui va
vraiment se passer sur le terrain
qu'est ce qui va se passer dans ma vie
la première fois je me dis que je vais
utiliser ça pour simplement faire le
point savoir où j'en suis là maintenant
puis ensuite où je veux aller qu'elle a
ma vision quelle est mon futur quelles
sont mes envies donc je vais les notés
de 1 à 3 et 3 et ton amerloques alors
revenons à l'analyse qui à 18 ans se
retrouve devant son choix universitaire
à ce moment-là je me dis c'est parfait
je suis 3 1 1
3 parce que je me connais j'ai 18 ans
tout est possible a aucun souci rien là
pouvoir l'arrêter
par contre niveau connaissances et
expériences je vois que encore le boulot
donc choisi de faire un dut tc et je me
dis à ce moment là je vais alliés
théorie et pratique à 21 ans je me dis
que cette fois ci je vais arrêter mon
parcours universitaire j'ai fait une
année erasmus en irlande
je ressors avec une licence éco-gestion
un diplôme en marketing et à ce moment
là je suis de 2,1
j'ai pas encore d'expérience il a fallu
que j'aille cette fois je fonce je
trouve mon premier job dans le marketing
digital parfait c'est absolument ce
qu'on m'a demandé de faire c'est ce que
j'ai appris j'ai sur le terrain je suis
commercial
je vais voir des clients n'importe quel
type de client je fonce je suis épanoui
aucun problème on me demande même un
objectif clair en une année je dois
réaliser sans contrat ok pas de souci
au bout de neuf mois je signe mon
centième contrat à ce moment là je me
sens 3 3 3 je sais tout je sais comment
le faire et j'ai déjà vécu beaucoup de
choses
parfait ma direction d'appel me
remercier de me convoque je vous refais
la scène madame beau merci beaucoup pour
votre engagement votre travail votre
dynamisme vous avez fait les rencontrer
en neuf mois pour vous remercier
on vous licencie pardon autant vous dire
que ce jour là je me retrouve 1 1 1
pourquoi on licencie j'ai tout fait
correctement
j'ai même été plus rapide j'étais
meilleure vendeuse et de surcroît la
plus jeune c'est pas juste c'est pas
normal
je me sens vraiment ébranlé dans mon adn
dans mes connaissances et dans le peu
d'expérience que j'ai c'est pas juste
mais je continue
cette fois ci je me dis allez j'ai
toujours rêvé de faire l'événementiel de
pouvoir créer de pouvoir accueillir des
stars de pouvoir organiser des
événements de vivre par passion on y va
je trouve l'opportunité est vraiment je
fonce dans le mur
parce que je crée une place qui n'existe
pas encore dans une nouvelle structure à
ce moment là je me sens un 2-2 malgré
tout mon premier licenciement ça m'a
quand même touché dans mes valeurs mais
bon peu importe
allez on va continuer on part dans
l'événementiel à ce moment là dans
l'événementiel je travaille 12 heures
par jour je crée je vends des espaces
publicitaires je fais les campagnes
d'affichage accueille les artistes
j'organisais tournée je suis absolument
épanouie quoique un peu fatigué je dois
avouer quand même de nouveau ma
direction vient me voir après deux ans
et demi
on y voit super ce que tu fais tes
hyperdynamique tu es un super couteau
suisse
c'est vraiment intéressant de savoir par
contre on va licencier sa collègue on
était plus on va lice l'ensieta
collègues et tu vas reprendre ses tâches
mais au niveau du salaire on pourra pas
faire mieux les temps sont durs ok je
fais le bilan je me dis ok j'ai déjà
perdu 10 kg sera à 12 heures par jour
deux fois plus de responsabilités pour
une reconnaissance qui en général
proches du zéro
je refuse la proposition et je pars sans
plan b à ce moment-là je me dis que je
suis un 2/3 de l'expérience j'en ai pris
en travaillant douze heures par jour
pendant trois ans aucun souci c'est bon
je suis à bloc je peux tout résoudre
connaissances gecko 23 ans donc il ya
encore pas mal de choses à apprendre
dans la théorie mais ok par contre au
niveau de l'adn la chanson ya quelque
chose qui va pas je me sens tout
simplement pas ma place je me dis que je
suis trop investi je suis trop
indépendante
c'est pas normal ce qui se passe donc à
ce moment-là je me dis ok je vais
changer de vie donc pour changer de vie
je vais partir cette fois en suisse
alémanique et je vais aller trouver un
poste dans la presse automobile
gros challenge
cette fois ci je suis 2-1 3-2 parce que
ça a l'air d'être en accord avec mes
valeurs
ça a l'air d'être en accord avec ma
vision je pense je le sens le salaire
plus stable puisque j'ai connu avant
connaissances autant vous dire que je ne
connaissais rien au journalisme très peu
dans l'espace dans la vente des espaces
publicitaires et que je ne savais même
pas la différence entre le logo peugeot
ou renault
il y avait clairement du boulot je me
dis ok pas de souci
cette fois ci j'y vais on va faire de
son mieux 1
à ce moment là je fais pas les mêmes
erreurs je me dis voilà je me suis
toujours rendu trop j'ai toujours été
trop à disposition de ma hiérarchie 3
disposition de mes collègues j'ai jamais
rien dit gibbons cette fois je vais
faire attention
je suis les heures de ma hiérarchie je
m'appuie sur mes collègues qui ont plus
d'expérience je rencontre mon chef qui
va devenir un vrai mentor pour moi et
qui va réussir à vraiment me donner
confiance en moi on réalise un chiffre
d'affaires record
vraiment on fait tout péter alors que le
monde de la presse et encore aujourd'hui
est vraiment dans une mauvaise situation
on passe devant les conseils de
direction on organise la venue de notre
journal sur le salon de l'automobile à
genève on présente
notre autre nos chiffres pardon devant
le conseil de direction
on est surmotivé tout se passe bien
ensuite on va même rentrer dans l'équipe
stratégique
c'est à dire qu'on est directement avec
le directeur du journal pour faire le
pilotage stratégique pour pouvoir
avancer savoir dans quel sens on va
partir avec ce journal quelle est la
stratégie en terme de communication de
prix tout ce que vous apprenez sur votre
votre échelle de connaissances parfait
je me sens 3 3 3 je suis en accord avec
tout mon chef part en vacances et à ce
moment là on m'impose un nouveau chef
et surtout j'ai interdiction d'en parler
ce nouveau chef en plus d'être imposé
ici je ne connais pas me demande la
moitié de ma clientèle il a une
situation familiale compliquée doit
faire du chiffre d affaires très
rapidement autant vous dire que là ni
vos connaissances expériences et adn je
sens que c'est pas le bon chemin je me
retrouve la veille de mon anniversaire
mais 25 ans avec une très jolie lettre
recommandée pour mon licenciement à
nouveau et cette fois ci je pars avec
mon chef sans raison sans aucun temps de
préparation sans salaire et sans
commission
bonjour au revoir merci c'est fini
je vous avoue que là il ya un certain
moment vous dit c'est pas possible je
suis 1 1 certes mais qu'est ce que j'ai
fait de faux et qu'est ce que je fais de
faux j'ai 25 ans je suis à mon troisième
poste
c'est la deuxième fois qu'on y sent
s'ils sont absolument aucune raison
j'ai respecté mes objectifs donc
qu'est-ce que je vais faire la chance
que j'ai eue à ce moment là c'est
d'avoir cet ancien chef qui est devenu
un mentor qui est devenu un ami qui m'a
dit on va pas se laisser faire
cette fois ci on attaque on va attaquer
et on va préparer le cas avec nos
avocats on va aller on va prouver que
voilà tout ce qu'on a tous qu'on a
rapporté tout ce qu'on a à mener pour la
société c'est pas normal qu'on parte
sans rien donc on se voit souvent on
prépare le cas ensemble et un jour il
reçoit un sms notre ancien directeur qui
dit simplement salut tu a monté une
boîte avec anaïs il se retourne vers moi
et me dit on d'une boîte et balmont jean
watts avec l'expérience que tu as en
création avec l'événementiel et le
marketing
moi j'ai la même expérience on semences
une agence de com si les autres ont
réussi pourquoi pas nous ok on fait le
pari
à ce moment là je suis 3 2 2 j'ai gagné
l'intégralité de mes procès reprend
d'anciens employeurs j'ai tout gagné
deux ans et demi de procédure c'est
parfait j'ai jamais touché un sou jamais
il a juste et est beaucoup plus malin
que la loi par contre aujourd'hui en
forme la semaine dernière je fêter les
80 ans en entreprise
on est six salariés on était avec une
cinquantaine de clients et sincèrement
c'est un vrai bonheur de faire ça alors
est ce que je déteste ancien patron pour
ce qu'il m'a fait ban on n'aime pas ça
s'appelle de nouveau faire acte de
résilience
sans lui j'aurais jamais eu l'expérience
que j'ai sans lui je n'aurais pas
rencontré on associe actuelle donc je
dirais presque je dis bien presque
merci lac de résidence est toujours en
cours
maintenant monter une société comme on a
pu entendre dans le pic d'avant c'est
pas une cure de jouvence
c'est extrêmement compliqué il faut être
motivé chaque jour par contre si vous
mots si vous montez une société où vous
faites partie d'un projet qui respecte
votre adn votre éducation ce qu'on vous
a appris qu'ils respectent votre valeur
qui respecte votre vision si en plus
vous avez déjà les connaissances dans ce
domaine là et l'expérience fond c'est
tous les jours j'apprends sur le domaine
dans lequel je travaille que la
communication j'apprends je me forme je
rencontre des clients je choisis avec
qui je travaille si je sens qu'on n'a
pas les mêmes valeurs humaines
on termine la relation avant même de
l'avoir commencée tous les jours j'ai
une équipe tous les matins donne de
l'énergie
et ça c'est vraiment un vrai voleur
pourtant avec ce que j'ai pu passer
donc qu'est-ce que c'est faire acte de
résilience que ce soit pour une
déception amoureuse
que ce soit pour un échec professionnel
en échec scolaire que ce soit pour un
drame familial
vous pouvez tous faire acte de
résilience ça prend du temps c'est long
mais le jeu en vaut vraiment la
chandelle
je vous donnais quatre points pour faire
acte de résilience
le premier c'est accepter la période de
déni de révolte et de colère
c'est pas juste c'est pas normal
acceptez-le énervé vous effectivement
seul chez vous acceptez là vous pourrez
pas faire autrement que passer cette
étape la deuxième
prenez du recul et laissez-vous du temps
le discours que je vous tiens
aujourd'hui il ya dix ans date de
résilience
il ya cinq ans date de résilience il ya
des années entières
donc prenez du temps et du recul fait
autre chose la troisième c'est d'en
parler à votre entourage la pire des
choses c'est de rester dans votre coin
et ne pas en parler je sais que c'est
pas facile on va vous donner des
conseils va vous dire mais tu verras ça
ira mieux
parlez-en ça vous aidera dans votre
cheminement est la dernière chose et
c'est ce que je suis aujourd'hui c'est
donner c'est de partager c'est de donner
cette expérience est de pouvoir
simplement si j'ai allumé une petite
lumière dans votre cerveau aujourd'hui
j'ai réussi mon acte de résilience
jusqu'au bout pour conclure la
résilience si je devais faire un seul
une seule phrase c'est que c'est la
capacité à profiter de la vie
malgré ses imperfections donc si je peux
conclure maintenant profiter relevez
vous faites vous confiance et surtout
continuez toujours à avancer simplement
et ça c'est effectivement mon premier
tatouage
voilà